[Music]  Maddie Ziegler reveals what Sia's really  like under those wigs she is the best  the insider with Yahoo caught up with a  13 year old at the industry dance awards  Wednesday night I am got the lowdown on  what's hiding under the singers famous  strands a beautiful loving caring face  people are always like is she pretty  is she ugly I'm like she's gorgeous and  it's not just on the outside but on the  inside too Maddie who starred in  lifetime's reality show Dance Moms shot  to fame when she showed off her killer  moves in Sia's chandelier music video  [Music]  now she's gearing up for the singers  nostalgic for the present tour I'm so  honored to be dancing with her like for  six weeks she is like my second mom  she's like a best friend to me and the  teen dished on rocking  CEA's look the wig gets a little itchy  sometimes but I've gotten really used to  it now so but you have to have like 150  pins in I'm doing like a flip it can't  fall off  [Music]